e
uh good morning it's uh the 10th of
March um and we're going to get ready to
open division 3 work session um on on um
division of long-term supports and
services um just to give folks some con
context uh today uh i' I'd like us to
see if we can get through this at uh by
noon and I realize to do that uh I have
to keep an obligation to only ask the
essential
questions um and I I'd hope all the
committee members uh keep in mind we
want to be able to wrap up at noon and
and then tomorrow is an interesting day
for us we'll be looking at the veterans
home and other um Direct Care Providers
the New Hampshire hospital Glen Cliff
home Hamstead hospital so that's uh
that's
tomorrow uh and then I think we we've
um we've somewhere we've squeezed in the
prescription drug affordability board I
can't really tell what day that is
Wednesday that's a Wednesday
okay and then Thursday we have session
and uh representative walner you you
asked me if we had anything on uh on the
14th and there's nothing on the calendar
and we talked through it in a working
group this morning and I don't think we
need to schedule anything on the
14th so but we are going to have to add
something on the
17th uh on the 17th I've asked Mr Ripple
to anticipate the new bills that we're
going to get as a division and I want to
schedule the 17th for us to hit the
bills so so that's where we are uh
overall um and uh welcome uh Dr Hardy no
not yet no no no not yet yeah Miss Hardy
and Mr White and and uh we're looking
forward to your
presentation great uh good morning
Nathan white Chief finance officer with
the Department of Health and Human
Services uh today in the governor's
operating budget um we'll be working
from Pages
8993 through
97 and then we will also be working from
pages4 through 1025 for the DD budget um
in front of you you also have the budget
briefing book again just as a reminder
it's for accounts over a million dollars
annually and with that said I will hand
it over to Melissa thank you Nathan I'm
Melissa Hardy I'm the division director
for long longterm supports and services
so thank you for having us this morning
I think in the interest of time uh I
know there's a lot of slides there so um
chairman Edwards if you're okay with me
kind of accelerating a little bit we're
we're in your hands okay so I think
probably starting on slide three to just
give a quick overview of the division
and the people that we serve um our
division has three distinct bureaus the
Bureau of Aging adult and Aging Services
we have the Bureau of Developmental
services and the Bureau of family
centered Services uh one thing I'd like
to point out um that's unique with us is
that we serve people throughout the
lifespan so our Bureau of family
centered Services serves um kids from
birth to up to age 21 um and then we
have our adult and Aging Services and
our DD services that serve um adults and
people with physical disabilities so um
in in talking with our stakeholders we
could have a parent who's taking care of
somebody on uh the DD waiver who also
receives CFI waiver services at the same
time so we overlap in a in a lot of
different ways um but have the honor of
serving people um throughout their
lifespan if needed so from a budget
context the BDS is probably what for
General funds probably 60% of your total
budget just approximately it it it's
it's the elephant in the room right for
BDS it's um yes I would say it's
significantly um higher than our other
divisions and and then um uh aging and
adult relative to family centered are
they effectively the same or no I would
say um Family centered service is uh is
less than um adult and Aging Services
for general f all right I I find that
kind of context useful so so thank you
sure um slide four is just again a brief
overview of what we do at the division
um providing guidance and technical
support and quality monitoring for our
provider networks um on all three of our
bureaus um so we're there as a resource
we do a lot of contracted uh provider
work um so giving them um the time and
the technical assistance in order to
make sure that we're following our Rules
of Engagement with our funders um and
making sure that we're reporting out on
a timely
basis we also work with um Meredith
too's group the division of program
quality and integrity uh when we do
things like uh file service file reviews
we do redesignation reviews um and
partner with her team to look at those
measures Slide Five is just a brief um a
high Lev look of our org chart uh for
your for your context uh so again just
shows the three different bureaus we
have a Chief Operating Officer of the
division um they're all here with me
today so if I need to phone a friend um
they're here to answer questions that I
us slide six is um our staffing and
vacancy rate so you can see we're pretty
proud of our vacancy rate um being at 4%
for the Bureau of adult and Aging
Services 15% for uh developmental
services and
6% um for family centered services so
15% relative to Workforce shortages
around the state 15% seems to be a
pretty relatively low vacancy rate I'm
I'm still a little bit curious um what
what what do you think the single
biggest or a couple biggest reasons for
you having a vacancy rate u in uh
BDS um I think we've spent a lot of time
uh fostering a a positive work
environment for people to want to work
in and then seeing the results of the
work um and talking and engaging with
families and providers I think that
gives a lot of context to you know why
people stay in their jobs it's not
necessarily for the glory it's for you
know seeing outcomes for the people that
we serve what I I I should have said it
a little different what do you have a
barrier to uh getting U closer to a a
four or five% vacancy rate what what
what what's sort of in the way yeah I
think because of the number we only have
27 authorized position so when you have
you know four that are vacant it really
you know skews that number so I think
right now we have four vacant positions
in BDS um so when you look at that I
just think the the end number is is low
to begin with thank
you um during the governor's budget we
were unfunded eight positions in the
division so three in the uh Bureau of
adult and Aging Services and five in BDS
okay um slide seven is really just um a
visual of our department and the
different ways that we help um across
the division with um our area so family
support we have a Adult Protective
Services in our division we provide
early intervention services for kids and
families um information referral food
and nutrition so just um a a kind of
like high level view of the different
arraya services
division and let me know if I'm going
too fast or too slow nope it's it would
be hard for you to go too fast now okay
were you one of the ones that came to us
in January to just give us the
information portion okay so this a lot
of this shouldn't be new to us right I
think Chris selo presented to this team
um just kind of the higher level
programmatic view of of our division
so um I know you heard a lot about the
com uh the Department's road map um and
our initiatives there so we are um
initiative seven for building a system
of care for healthy aging which you've
probably heard a lot about um in hb2 of
2023 and the work going onwards um that
we're doing for that and then initiative
eight is strengthening the developmental
disabilities program and systems so
looking at uh parity and rates and
looking at a reimbursement system that
is
predictable Slide N I'm sorry I'm a
little slow so at the bottom of slide
eight on goal two develop and propose a
new reimbursement rate
structure can can you can you just give
us like four sentences what what the old
and what the new what are we doing there
yep so we contracted with with an
actuary to look at the actual costs of
providing our services in the in the DD
field um worked with them for about a
year and a half two years on services
and um our rates hadn't been uh studied
I think since
so what we found was our rates were
significantly lower in comparison to not
only other states but you know what the
actual cost of doing that business is
and we we link that directly to um
having Services authorized but not
having providers to provide those
services so it's great that you know it
that everyone's funded for services but
if you can't find a provider because
they don't get an adequate reimbursement
rate for services um we're we're not
going to be able to provide the service
so is the expectation that we're going
to probably increase rates overall in
the Aggregate and to draw out more
Supply and the process of doing that
we're going to have both an increase in
quantity and an increase in the price so
our total uh spend at the state is
likely to end up more it'll ends up more
in the short term I think our our our
strategy or our proposal was to focus on
those services that keep that are lower
cost and keep people um in the community
is is there money in this budget for for
a prior yeah it was a prioritized need
that we put in that was not funded
okay all right thank you representative
walner it looked like you might have a
question there all right go ahead uh
yeah representative priest thank you
you're in the sun there it's kind of
hard to see
great yay thank you for taking my
question um can you give us some numbers
of how many um aging adults are in
long-term facility ities versus home
care and and what are the needs and what
are the
unsupportive needs out
there I I can give you the number so in
um in our waiver we have to report out
UND duplicated counts of people that we
serve so on the aging and adult waiver
which is the choices for Independence or
the CFI waiver we serve about
4,161
individuals um in contrast to the
nursing facility care so it's in lie of
Nursing Facility care um they're
averaging 3-month average for nursing
facility care is about
3,688 individuals in our nursing
homes um on the developmental Services
waiver we serve
5,061 individuals just on the waiver um
for our uh acquired brain disorder
waiver we serve 228 folks and then on
our inhome support waiver which is our
children's developmental disabilities
waiver we serve
488 children I do want to say that our
service delivery system certainly serves
a lot more people than the people just
on the waivers um so for example we
would say um on the on the DD side of
things we serve over 15,000 families and
people in general when we're looking at
all the services not necessarily just um
people who are on the DD
waiver as a followup how many addition
people are asking for services but you
can't provide
services so we don't have a wait list
for services um funding for services let
me say that we don't have a funding
weight list but again finding providers
to um provide the services that people
need at the rates that we have
especially on the DD waiver um is hard
so we're able to fund everybody which is
great but we're not able to provide all
slide nine is just uh and you can read
these these are just some of our
accomplishments that we've had over the
past two years for each of our bureaus
um I will say one thing that is uh
prevalent throughout all the bureaus is
our investment in it and I'll talk a
little bit about that our infrastructure
and how we've changed um and are able to
not only track um data better but also
produce some outc comes that we weren't
able to really do before because it was
a manual process or it was done by an
outside system that uh unfortunately
does not is no longer operable so we've
spent a lot of time um creating
processes in um New Heights that
automate a lot of things for us we can I
can highlight some of those things as we
move ahead um I do also want to say and
I'm sure a lot of people have heard um
on the Bureau of Developmental services
on July 1st 1 2023 we finally closed out
our corrective action cap that we had
with oh yes a representative stram knows
all about it um we were able to close
that out and meet compliance and that
was um something that had been out there
since 2017 I believe um that we've been
working toward so you know this team and
our providers and our area agencies have
worked really hard to gain compliance
with CMS and give us the nice uh letter
that that is closed out um so we can
move towards you know move from
compliance and CMS and you know looking
at those regulations every day to really
how do we strengthen and make it a
system that meets the needs of the
people that we serve so I just wanted to
note that it's been a long process for
for the bureau and the division so I
wanted to give that um some some
nine sorry so so I I looked ahead
through uh 14 where you've got it
enhancements and let me just say that I
I I love the fact that your division
specifically got into the IT issues
because this is one of my big things is
you know what are we doing to leverage
our it to drive productivity or to
improve you know reimbursements from the
feds or from others and it looks like in
a lot of these are cleaning up
process um but um what of of of these
that have been completed or in progress
which which one do you think has the
biggest impact on driving
productivity um I would like I like can
I have two because I feel like you can
have two all right I would say um the
transition for adult our Adult
Protective Services to go into New
Heights um it just creates a lot of
efficiencies for our sta St as it
relates to case consultation notes um
we're able to pull data um a lot easier
than we were in our old system um that's
not really supported anymore so I I
would say adult protection going into
new heights but then a very close uh or
maybe equal would be our Bureau of
Developmental Services also going into
New Heights where we're able to um
automate a lot of functions as it
relates to service authorizations we can
see where they're at in the process
um our providers can see into that
system as well so they can see if a
service authorization has been submitted
you know is it waiting for the
Department is it waiting for the
provider just creating a lot of
transparency so it's not something
that's stuck in a spreadsheet at the
bureau level um where at any point a
provider can go in and look to see um
where their case is at so I think those
two would be our our two biggest
accomplishments outstanding so so if I
may make a request for the oversight
committee occasionally you talk to the
oversight committee uh one of the times
coming up would you would you do just a
special focus on leveraging of it sure
okay yes I can do that thank you you're
welcome and I I do want to add a little
note to the it I know that there's been
um you know there's been a lot
accomplished over the bium and I think
um you know really looking at if we were
to reduce our uh our allocations for it
not only this is great right this this
creation of these IT services but we
also have to make sure it's funded you
know going forward for maintenance um
and any any other updates that you know
will streamline our processes and make
uh not only the lives of our staff
better but you know quicker Service
delivery to to the folks that we serve
so I just want to put a plug out there
for that so you you brought up a really
big expense item maintenance uh gen
generally New Heights is budgeted for
maintenance in the these departments Mr
White or or is that under a big catchall
in the in your department of it in the
department I I believe that's budgeted
in class 27 within the office of the
commissioner than the Bureau of
Information
Services okay
so so at some point there may be kind of
a a training or a transparency thing for
the the members just so that we know
that new for example is helping support
specific departments and correlating the
costs with the with the benefit could
help us I don't think we need to worry
about that in this budget cycle but
it'll be an ongoing sure I I I think the
um the presentation that Dave weers had
provided early on a number of weeks ago
had a breakdown of each system and then
the the the benefiting or uh parties or
or Services delivered to uh specific
parties so you probably you may have a
reference document but we're more than
happy to talk about that in the future
you so slide 16 goes into now I'll talk
about each of our bureaus and go through
their um accounting units uh we'll start
with the Bureau of adult and Aging
Services so slide 16 just gives a an
overview of what we do in the Bureau of
adult and Aging Services so um just to
note we did have a bureau name change we
you probably heard of us as the Bureau
of elderly and Adult Services and um and
looking at age friendly language and
we're all aging and I have a little I'm
not wearing it now but a little pin
saying aging everyone's doing it right
so um it's not just elderly I think
elderly you know has that negative
connotation um and prevents some people
who are aging that might you know want
to access preventative Services that we
serve um but don't consider themselves
elderly so we were able to um you know
we enhanced our name to adult and aging
uh to take out that kind of elderly
connotation um and that we're all adults
and we're all aging so uh we might need
services at some
point um we're looking at strengthening
our uh Adult Protective Services again
through the it enhancement but also
looking at training opportunities for
them we're seeing in in a couple of
slides ahead um you know we're seeing
some Trends in um adult protection uh as
far as what we're seeing for cases um
more cases as it relates to scams for
older adults um you know Financial
exploitation and a lot of um self-
neglect or isolation so we'll talk a
little bit about that we administer
under the Bureau of adult and Aging
Services our choices for Independence
1915c Medicaid waiver so that provides
services to adults in the community um
who meet Nursing Facility level of care
but choose to have their services um the
community we also develop uh we also
determine medical eligibility for level
of care not only for people on the
choices for Independence Weaver but also
for um individuals who are um admitting
into the nursing facilities to ensure
that they meet and need that level of
care medically so so on that bullet
specifically to what extent today are
the counties officially responsible for
helping with the uh medical eligibility
level of care
the counties are not responsible at this
time to to be part of the process we are
working with uh maram County as they
have a few doing a pilot with Marat
County to um use their they have some
Navigators um in their system to see if
we can um transfer some of that you know
from their waiting lists for eligibility
not only for the nursing facility but
for CFI and have them kind of be a quasi
arm of the department to help determine
eligibility and and then on on the
previous bullet about the waiver so I
understand the waiver we we when we
asked for it and received it we um
basically made some uh commitments
things that look like commitments of how
many people we would have in CFI at each
year yes and and as I understand it
we're we're only about 60 65% of those
targets um what kind of potential uh
problem would that cause with the
federal government if we don't basically
achieve what we said we would with the
CFI I I think we would have to give them
an explanation of why we're not seeing
the growth in those numbers we've talked
internally about you know when we do our
waiver amendment to really look at that
projection to see if that's something
that is attainable in New Hampshire um
not that we're not an aging State
because we all know we are um but we
also have to have enough people who are
eligible for Medicaid in order to be on
the waiver so what we're seeing is our
age is you know the the number of older
adults is climbing but the number of
older adults that qualify financially
for Medicaid is not climbing at that
same rate yeah so what I think I heard
you say is is that we don't anticipate
any problem with the feds we may just
have to re update our waiver yeah and we
we would do that in our next Amendment
just to say you know explain why our
projection isn't what you know is being
served and you know any interventions to
help that
uh uh yes representative seaworth thank
you Mr chairman uh kind of as a followup
to that is
there um a connection so if we're at 65%
on what we expected to do is there a
Federal grant that we have to curtail
because because we're not eligible for
it or is it all taken care of in the
waiver processes yeah I would say we're
good from from that side it's taken care
in the waiver we also have have um we
received another Federal grant outside
of um the CFI waiver called money falls
the person which is um 100% federal
funds that really focus on transitioning
individuals out of nursing facilities to
remain in the community so we also have
that project that we're standing up and
operationalizing
now thank you yep and then we contract
in adult and Aging Services with
providers um in the community to um
Carry Out uh services that are funded
through other funding streams so I think
what you'll see um in in this Bureau
particularly we braid a lot of funding
together so we get funding from not only
Medicaid and not only the state but we
have um older Americans act money that
we get in in in Social uh service block
grants um different just different
streams that fund um preventative
community- Based Services so you'll see
um it's not I think on the other uh in
our other divisions you'll see that it's
50% Medicaid 50% State dollars this is a
little different when we're talking
about the funding of things like meals
and nutrition um Family caregiver
support uh in home care so Nursing Care
in somebody's home or or housekeeping so
it's a breeding of of multiple funding
streams not just your traditional
Medicaid and state funds so I'm jumping
to slide 19 and I'm looking at um uh at
the bottom the number of sexual abuse uh
reportings um what is is there a general
uh setting in which those seem to be
more more predominant are these settings
like uh you know private nursing homes
public nursing homes CFI I'm just I'm I
don't have if you don't have the data
don't don't worry about it it's an
information only question it just makes
me curious if we have something that we
should be doing that setting base to to
try to reduce that I'm sure we have the
data I just don't have it with me but um
we can look at that to see if there's
any Trend or um uh environment where
we're seeing that more prob and then
exploitation does that include uh like
Financial exploitation is that
predominantly what that is that kind of
exploitation it can be or it can be um
you know people just mostly Financial I
will say but it can be you can exploit
people emotionally by you know uh
manipulating them into making you know
them feel bad for somebody else so it is
I would say mostly Financial but it
could be in other forms as well all
right thank
you a question represent torski thank
you good morning thanks for being here
um I don't know if we're going to get to
this in the coming slides if so put me
off I have a question explicitly about
hb2 that affects your department on page
49 section 98 at the
bottom um regarding congregate housing
and services that it will be the program
it will be suspended for the coming bium
can you please talk about that in the
impact of what that could have yes I
will get to that okay yes I will talk
about looking forward to it thanks yes
thank you are there any other hp2 items
in there I mean let's I I think that's a
great question uh but are do we have
multiples of them you want to go over um
that affects this Bureau I don't know
but that one jumped out to me okay in
the last couple days all right great
question go ahead uh representa
walner thank you so while we're at um
The Adult Protective Services how many
how many Adult Protective Services
Workers do you have in total we have
70 and what kind of a case load are they
carrying they're carrying about
97 um 97 individuals on their case
load which is which is there's no
National Standard in Lo for adult
protection we're really uh working with
um the national folks on developing
something like that there is no standard
I think in other um avenues that provide
Protective Services they do um but there
is no National Standard certainly we
would like that number to come down um
as again as our aging population grows
in New Hampshire we just expect the
number of adult protection protective
cases to grow um I do think we have some
opportunities to better partner with
with some of our community
organizations um you know if it's not
necessarily an abuse or neglect area
that somebody needs you know more
informational referral or or um
community- Based Services to be able to
hand off um that from an APS worker to a
community- based provider so we're
working on those connections as
well go ahead so do you have on all of
these cases does the case worker have
yes yes I'm looking at my team back
there I see the shaking head out there
yes um face to face um and so you can
you can tell I think they use a priority
that we have we have some
decision-making trees that we use in APS
to kind of um see which which uh person
should be seen sooner which person maybe
be able to be helped by an aging or
disability Resource Center maybe
somebody else is being served by by the
Bureau of uh um mental health services
so we have an algorithm to kind of
prioritize those at higher
risk and one other question is there a
hotline or a re a referral number that
the public has yes um I think it's on
one of the slides and we also have now
as part of our IT solutions we also have
24-hour reporting online so anyone can
report allegations of abuse or neglect
um that that's on an online port that
people can submit and that's something
new that we instituted this year so um
247 ability to report great thank you
representative priest did you have a
question my question was the same as the
previous representative thank you I
continue on slide 17 we talk about um
this is where we have the aps accounting
units I didn't know if you had questions
or wanted to review this we do um um you
can see here in accounting unit 9250 was
where all of our APS staff are H housed
and paid for um significant General
funds there that's historical for APS as
far as the federal government not
funding the service however um in 2023
they started giving us a small amount of
money um which is that accounting unit
4046 um for adult protective operation
so um we're starting to see a little
little bit of um assistance with the
federal government and providing funds
for adult protection can can you jump to
slide 22 or or did you have things in
highlight go go ahead turn your mic on
before we leave this slide yeah quick
question you're still on 17 yes okay uh
just helping me with the terminology of
minimum allotment state could you
explain what that means yeah sure um so
the the federal government has a formula
uh in in determining how much states
will receive in federal dollars so
looking um at and I think main main
Vermont and Rhode Island were all um a
minimum allotment State um due to a
couple of factors population um people
who are uh in poverty um number of Aging
adults so they they look all look at all
of that and create um a scale in which
states uh receive those dollars so St
like Massachusetts I was looking at the
numbers they receive a bit more but I
would only say maybe like 20 or $30,000
more not not a significant amount of
money um and this amount of money for
the aps formula grant is pretty um low
comparative to you know other Federal
funding um but it's a start we'll we'll
welcome are you on 22 now or is there
no okay slide 22 um is our aging and
disability Resource Centers so I I CL I
clustered these together for a couple of
reasons um again this is kind of how we
see the breeding of funding work so in
9565 that is uh where our funding for
our adrcs our aging and disability
Resource Center is also known as service
link uh previously known as service link
we have seven contracted providers um at
13 different sites throughout the state
uh they provide information referral
information referral supports um person
centered
counseling uh they administer our family
caregivers Support Program throughout
the state um and ALS also um they were
given U additional dollars in hp2 of 23
um to enhance the system of care for
healthy aging
um so we have that we also in
3317 we have the senior Medicare uh
Patrol program mostly federal funds that
teaches um older adults who are on
Medicare to look at and be aware of any
Medicare scams that might be going on
and then 8925 is the Medicaid services
Grant uh which is the state health
insurance education program uh 95%
federal funds and it really is a a
counseling program to help people
understand their options when it comes
to
Medicare any questions on those I don't
see
any um slide 23 is just a kind of a
visual on the system of care for healthy
aging um so just wanted to point out you
know we are underway we were able to
again secure that funding in hp2 in 23
um so that included uh a a study to look
at our our coordinated system uh some in
some funding for it technology to create
dashboarding um reporting requirements
we did get that um significant a good
significant amount of funding for person
centering counseling programs that are
within our adrcs and the department
received two positions to help with the
system of care for healthy aging um so
we so that was an
hb2 um this graphic really just shows
you know obviously the the individuals
that we serve in the middle and then all
the supports in places of support that
um people can go to in order to navigate
go ahead represent tki so slide 23 is
all about this wonderful work that
happened with hb2 where we last bium
where are we going to be at now in this
bium with this same work are we going to
be able to continue it is my question
funding wise or just um programmatically
wise both okay I can talk um from a
program standpoint our next our next um
our next steps in the system of care for
healthy aging is we still haven't um
completed the dashboarding piece so
again kind of the it in in real time so
people know um what services are
available to them um you know if if a
provider has uh a capacity to take on
somebody who needs home health care for
example um so that has yet to be
completed uh but that's part of that
appropriation in hb2 of last year we
have been able to
um start and what we're seeing is an
increase in home visiting with the
inclusion of the dollars for the person
centered counseling so um we've been
seeing the number of home visits from
those um individuals that work at our
adrcs um to go out to the home um and
kind of it's always good to have an
extra set of eyes on somebody um or if
somebody physically can't come into the
adrc or have communication issues uh
through telephone so we're also ramping
adrcs we have 63 staff um Statewide in
in our
adrcs um that's just in in a brief kind
of overview of slide 24 of what what
they do which I I talked a little bit
about person centered counseling access
to uh family caregiver information and
explore options that you know are either
covered by Medicaid or Medicare
um slide 25 is just um the locations
that we have throughout the state um so
walk-in locations physical locations for
people to come in and again um those
those workers can go out and do home
in slide 26 is just a breakdown of um
the total Encounters in in state fiscal
year 24 that our adc's had and also uh
um again I'm focusing on the home visits
because I think it's really important to
have eyes on some some folks um and then
kind of Total Staffing by each um
adrc so so I have a a a vision of a
virtual Health Care system to where we
don't need to Mo move people around on
roads as much do you do you how long do
you think it might be to where uh we can
provide a tremendous amount of this
support U virtually through something
like tele medicine instead of spending
windshield time moving people around
yeah I think we do a lot of that now
where a lot of our encounters like we
call them encounters but are either you
know on a zoom or on teams or via
telephone um you know not only for I
think we learned that through Co that we
can get a lot done without being face
Toof face with somebody physically um
and it's also it allows us to touch more
people um you know to be able to be more
efficient in our time so you know time
Trav traving um from Claremont to to
coldbrook is isn't really efficient so
if we can leverage those um and connect
more providers with that tele medicine
so would you say you're about half of
your visits now are virtual oh I would
say more than more than half are um you
know either via telephone or visual or
virtual and and do you see us hitting
80% at some point I would think that
would be a good goal I I I don't know I
don't have the number now but would
think that you know the number of inhome
visits would really be limited to people
who may be at risk or uh people that
don't have the ability to navigate
technology um or have the ability to you
know uh have the internet or um you know
some of those other barriers so one last
question here and then I I think you uh
representative walner has a question but
um Dr Ballard chairs a tele medicine
committee with people from around the
state
and they try to aggregate data that
reflects the changing use of tele it's
just generally called tele medicine do
you do you think your data ends up in uh
his data sets I wouldn't at this time I
don't think so because it's not
considered medicine I'm not I'm not sure
if he's coming from a you know a medical
provider yeah um tele medicine if if you
ever have a cup of coffee with them ask
him about it cuz I because what we're
trying to document in that committee is
uh the the changing nature of healthc
care delivery and what we may do to
facilitate it to make it go faster so
all right representative Waller did you
have a question representative tersi
thanks can you explain um to me why the
Hillsboro County numbers are so low on
these home visits and encounters when
it's the largest county I don't
understand that I I think part of it has
been our ability to retain staff in in
that specific office so just our uh
staff capacity which we're seeing um
improve
um other than that I don't have um
another answer as to why that's lower
okay do you have a followup information
my followup is I'm really concerned
looking at that number compared to
Rockingham County and Marram County with
it's half of those counties that tells
me that there are a lot of people who
are not getting the support and the the
contact that they should be getting yeah
and I think if you're looking at the
particular home visit number with um 37
in 24 and 25 you know for the half a
year that we've been or a little bit
more we're up to 24 so we are seeing a
little bit of a climb their encounters
though if you look that's still
6,716 encounters so that could be um
again you know it could be a telephone
call it could be a zoom meeting so not
necessarily a home visit but we're still
have a a significant uh amount of
encounters I I do see like Marram County
and Rockingham County have have higher
encounters than than Hillsboro County
yeah I mean just if you look at
population alone they should be
Hillsboro County numbers of contact
should be encounter should be up there
with the other two if not more so okay
thank
you representative Daniels I just follow
following up on that you list the number
of home visits but you don't list the
number of
homes so you know going going back to uh
H Hillsboro County 37 home visits but
how many times that did how many homes
did you visit it's a good question I can
look at I don't have it with me but we
can get some unduplicated counts so
number of actual people versus if I go
to a home two times three times you know
is that counted as three visits or one
visit I can get that for you thank you
you're
welcome and of and of course however
you're doing it the data would be
captured consistently like we wouldn't
have a Hillsboro issue where they're may
be reporting the data differently even
though the yeah everyone uses the same
reporting so I don't think it's a data
collection
issue slide
27 um is our accounting units for um
again still in our same Bureau but um
our Administration on Aging our social
service block grant and our volunteer
opportunities so
7872 um the administration on Aging
funds a variety of different services so
anything from nutrition
services uh home modifications and
caregiver
support and 9255 that's our social
service block grant um
again um funds things like medical Adult
Day services in home care uh chore
Services emergency support resit hom
delivered meals and Homemaker services
so so is this I assume Meals on Wheels
is part of that yes is is all are all of
meals and wheels in this area or are
they spread out in multiple accounting
units they are spread out in multiple
accounting units so um certainly um they
are under the administration on Aging
funds they're in the social service
block grants um they're also in you know
we have a significant um state funded
portion of meals and nutrition do you
know if we do one big contract with them
or do we do like 12 different contracts
per program yeah so um for for meals we
have 10 contracts that braid all that
funding in together um so 10 10
providers with their contract but
includes you know funding from the
administration aging from the block
grant from the different sources all
right
thanks represent
noo yeah and looking at page uh 900 I'm
just want is this another case where we
have a crosswalk issue where
money I see you know there's a 100,000
in there for fiscal year 25 adjusted and
then goes to zero is that another where
it's shifted to another
accounting unit um you're looking at
9010 uh class
103 yeah one I'm looking at 103 and I
guess I'm looking at yeah so there was
in chapter 79 laws of 2023
hb2 uh there was an appropriation made
for the Foster grandparent program which
is currently not
funded okay so that's why it went to
zero okay yes and then the other a quick
followup on um on the volunteer
activities how many how many people are
we serving
[Applause]
there I do have that I just have to get
page so for the volunteer um it's it's
the senior companion program which has
been um in existence in New Hampshire
since
1974 and so when we look at um 2020 uh
four numbers we um have 75 companions
that have provided uh over 50 3,000
hours of services to
457 um older adults so that funding um
provides you know mileage reimbursement
a small stip in Education and Training
to those um senior
you and uh chairman Edwards if I can
just add one thing on the um in the
accounting unit 9010 uh class 103
because the Foster um grandparent
program is not funded in the current B
anym I did send Kevin an email over the
weekend indicating that we'd probably
want to consider suspending the
corresponding statute for the bayum if
that's not going to be funny going
forward all right good
um slide 28 is specific to nutrition
services so just giving um you some
information on the um satisfaction
surveys that we send out to folks that
Access Nutrition so it could be Meals on
Wheels it could be our grab andg go
services or it could be congregate meal
settings so um you know we serve a lot
of people um 30 over 37,000 folks we've
served over almost 2 million meals um
and you know I think I think one of the
things I want to highlight is that from
a Meals on Wheels perspective you know
61% of our folks say it's their primary
source of
nutrition um and then you know 41% say
it's the only person they see all week
is the person that delivers their meals
um so not only is it providing nutrition
services but it also provides another
layer of support um and oversight of of
folks so if somebody didn't pick up
their meals our meals and wheels
providers are great at notifying you
know either their their agency or us to
say we haven't seen you know Melissa in
a couple of days I think we need to
check in on her or I saw her and she was
looking a little different today it's
it's a great you know supplemental set
of eyes uh for people who are homebound
um and receiving meals so not only does
it provide nutrition but also that extra
layer so so I love meals and wheels CU I
had surgery on my ankle year or two ago
and I was stuck in my comfy chair for 3
months and they would come into my house
and feed me right there at my chair and
you know ask me how my day was going
doing like a little mental health check
uh I don't know if they did that
intentionally but it was there uh the
only issue I had with them is that they
they didn't do weekends they didn't do
Saturday and Sunday it was Monday
through Friday it was one meal and and
for a big fat guy like me it wasn't
enough food but other other than that
they were really good representative
walner thank you so when Meals on Wheels
goes out and delivers a meal and a day
goes by or two days goes by and they
haven't seen anyone who actually then
follows up and do you actually go out to
the house yeah so um with our contract
there is um kind of a a safety net so if
somebody does see something like that
they they report it um to their
supervisor but we have contract managers
that manage all the 10 meals and wheels
contracts so the expectation would be
that they report up to us and then we
can partner either with you know the
local adrc or if it's something that
we're concerned from a protective
standpoint we can look at adult
protection or even a wellness check
through the local you know Police
Department to make sure that person is
okay so so can I do a time check um I I
I think we've got U 40 more minutes that
we're pushing towards and then I want to
open up for some questions around
possible um shifts to mcos so how how do
you think we're doing you got another 40
minutes what do you think for uh I would
say we still have um the developmental
Services waivers which I think might
take some time so I don't know if you
want to jump to BDS um or if there are
any large question we still have we
haven't also talked about um CFI or
nursing facilities in theas might want
to jump that first I I think I think we
might get to the CFI issue when we start
talking about a potential shift to manag
care okay I think okay all right um so
so as I'm flipping through the
think where do you think we can go I
think you got some good stuff in here
but but do we but you have good write up
too so can we just read those and and we
could get into the DD area yep I was
thinking we could do slide oh go ahead
sorry I had flagged a specific question
that you're sl you want to talk you have
a question you want to ask I'm sorry a
specific line item on hb1 that we're
about to you're flipping Pages by that I
have okay what what uh page number would
you want to have us highlight so you
could ask your question on page 31 I
have a question about the um accounting
I think this
is the CFI and the
um nursing home yes is that correct
corre okay um looking at the 506 line
almost all the way at the bottom it
looks like there is a um drop in funding
to the um 26 the 125
and I'm just curious if um that funding
that we put in there with Medicaid rates
last go around if it's still in there if
they're going to be supported at the
same level or if there's going to be a
change in the support that they get your
your question is very clear I I'm just
not tracking which pages and numbers P
yeah all the way at the bottom there's
a actually a nursing home payment line
and there's also a home support waiver
Services line and it looks like 504
nursing homes gets a big bump but it
looks like the home support waiver
service does not there's also asteris on
there with footnotes so I'm just hoping
we can dig into both of those and make
sure that um both of those are seeing
the proper proper level of support sure
so if you if you look at so on page uh
92 account unit 2152 I I'll start with
line 506 so this is the CFI waiver
payments in in the current
bium uh this was the 506 line was
budgeted at 92 million 100
million so what you're looking at there
is you're looking at the actuals and
that has the applied rate increases from
hb2 so when you're looking at the
adjusted authorized you're actually
seeing a bit of carry forward that was
not spent in the first year so the
projection going forward are based on on
the actual expenses and the adjusted
authorized doesn't necessarily um it's
not necessarily a good comparator but in
in the budget we have Incorporated those
rate increases into that um historically
we also used classes um 505 and 529 but
those have been wrapped up into into
class 506 which is why you're not seeing
that anymore and the reason that we did
that was because we had some challenges
relative to the administration of that
so if we needed to move money in between
that we could be looking at a 5e delay
and we wanted to ensure that Services
were paid um on time and in a timely
manner uh in the event we had to go back
through so so that was a change that was
made by this committee um in
consolidating those lines in the last
budget and in the next cycle you won't
see those lines anymore
okay could we talk about the the
increase in the nursing home rates which
does look like a significant increase
sure so in the in the class 504 line
there these are the the nursing facility
payments for Medicaid eligible
individuals um there there's a bit of a
history here so in state fiscal year 24
the budgeted amount was 233
million and you'll see that the expense
there is $263 million so about $30
million higher um I believe Henry Litman
Andor myself have talked to the fiscal
committee and members of this committee
about uh some of the nursing facility
change of ownership challenges that the
state has been seeing where we've seen I
think 18 18 nursing facilities change
ownership that's led to a number of
Downstream issues including back billing
which has been uh pretty significant uh
last year I don't remember off the top
of my head but I thought we saw over $14
million of back billing from prior years
and that's a that is a historical
anomaly and likely a function of both
delays and billing during the pandemic
um as well as the change of ownership
issue that the state is
experiencing what you when you look at
State fiscal year 25 and the adjusted
authorized we have already moved um
through the department-wide transfer
this year so far um I believe it was uh
$10 million already uh in this year
we're expecting to have to move an
additional $10 to $30 million as well to
continue to deal with the back billing
issue so when you look at um State
fiscal years 26 and 27 we looked at a
period of 8 years of growth to to
estimate the numbers that we would need
based on Trends and utilization and
that's why those numbers are showing an
increase there wow okay so it's not
necessarily choices being made to sync
more money in the nursing homes as
opposed to CFI which keeps people in
their
homes yes administrative delays and
snafus and payments that were just
trying to pick up the
pieces and backfill as you said I I I
think it's more than administrative
delays it's it's some of the challenges
that we've seen uh with ownership that
are are resulting in those things so I
wouldn't I mean that may be the effect
but when you're looking at the cause
it's it's where you know I think Henry
said the other day we've had a third of
our nursing facilities change in
ownership in the past couple of years
okay that's that's pretty significant
and that has caused a degree of
instability and it's affected the the
back billing that we've seen included in
there as well is also the rate increases
from hb2 um so so so there's a number of
different factors okay I just wanted to
make sure that this was not a uh
investing in nursing homes as opposed to
CFI which we all know was not the best
choice that is correct thanks so my
impression over the last year or two is
the department really prioritizes the
CFI and trying to make it happen so um
so I if it's not reflected here it's not
a reflection I to think on their
prioritization they they're having other
issues with getting CFI really ruled
out yeah so so representative Stringham
yeah I mean my understanding was yes CFI
is prioritized over nursing homes but
nursing homes were prioritized over
hospital stays and that and that part of
the reason why we were uh supporting uh
rate increases in hb2 last by Anum uh uh
and um I guess you know the um
suspension what pro- share increase or
something uh the 2% was so that there
would be more nursing home
capacity uh to free up free up the
hospital uh my question one of my
questions is uh what percent of the beds
are and our County increased uh uh open
a wing and increased by about 15% in the
last two years the number of of
individuals they're able to serve so I'm
wondering uh what percentage of this
increase is due to uh more people taking
the service versus the rates if we have
that and then if you have numbers of
what percent of the beds are private
versus County that would be um
interesting
I I do know just um I do know there's
reporting on uh the fiscal committee
dashboard that looks at Trends as far as
utilization in nursing homes it's like a
three-month Trend so we can see um you
know the number of people that are
served in nursing homes I don't have
that in front of me but we can get that
to you as far as you know looking at
those numbers um I will say that um you
know nursing facilities do play a vital
role in our whole system of care whether
it's you know providing short-term
services for people to get better and
transition back to the community or for
people who truly require that level of
care and supervision um so it's not to
say that they're not you know they're
not they're not prioritized because
people generally want to live at home
right they nobody kind of says I I can't
wait to get into the nursing home but
the nursing home certainly is a is a
part of our system that's vital you know
from a step down from a hospital and
then hopeful transition onto a CFI or
other um supports that we have to
maintain you know more preventative
Services from that hospitalization back
facility a little editorial note in here
um uh I I believe the department is
tracking over 100 questions from us um
most of them are informational some of
them uh drive directly at decision
making uh we'll we'll need to make um
with a focus I think on General funds
management and so I've I've I've asked
Mr White as he's going through the 100
questions to prioritize those in which
in his professional discretion think are
probably related to us making a a dollar
or Manpower decision relative to good
information good background about the
situation not that he's going to lose
those or forget those but just if you've
been asking questions wondering where
the answers are I think I I think we got
to prioritize answers that may drive uh
budget
decisions so all right do you do you
have other questions I I think it's a
good point M uh uh Mr chairman I would
say in this area we're going from 120
million to 180 million over the B Anum
and general funds nursing homes
so go
um slide 32 is just some information
about our CFI waiver again um
informational for for you so just our um
eligibility some of our eligibility
requirements some of our services that
were delivered in the average cost uh
based on claims uh in the past so you
can see you know obviously it's it's
less expensive to take care of somebody
in their home than it is in a nursing
facility or in a hospital setting for
long-term um placement so uh it is a
priority uh for us and and you know
federally to to main maintain people at
home um it's not only where people want
service um slide 30 again I'm a little
slow so on 32 Under The Sur service
examples um I'm I'm just I'm just
wondering if um in the future we we
should be explicitly pointing out that
we we're providing virtual support or
virtual services or I I I I don't know
how you'd want to phrase that but but
but I I do like the idea of of making it
more clear that not all of these are
okay thank
you um slide 33 is just more of a a
procedure a procedural slide on how um
the department works with our
contractors um to uh determine
eligibility for um CFI so it's a it's a
process where we contract with a uh a
contractor that goes and and meets with
the individual in person does an
assessment brings that information back
to the department where we make the
decision if somebody is eligible or
ineligible from a medical standpoint um
for CFI Services um and then uh go from
there so if somebody is ineligible for
CFI what other services can they be
connected to whether that's Services
through the block grant or older
Americans act um to to prevent you know
Nursing Facility placement or
hospitalization
slide 34 is just trending over the past
since 20 um
20 2004 excuse me um looking at our
trending from the orange line is um
Nursing Facility totals and the blue
line is uh CFI totals so we're seeing
you know a little bit of growth there as
far as you know moving from uh
institutional based care to home and
care representative walner so this
indicates the number of people not yeah
this indicates the number of like the
percentage of clients that are um in CFI
thank slide 35 is more accounting units
so money falls the person is 100% uh
federally funded helps people transition
um and stay in the
community we have health promotion
contracts we have the Alzheimer's
disease and Related
Disorders um which uh is 100% General
funds but 100% of that uh funding goes
to individuals who are caring for
somebody with alzheimer's disease in the
form of a respit grant so it could be um
you know providing Home Care
Services a respit stay for somebody in a
facility for a caregiver that needs a
needs a a little bit of a break um so
100% of that money goes into grants for
caregivers um and then 2165 is civil
monetary penalties those are the
penalties that are collected based um on
citations from nursing facilities and
then reinvested into programs and
services to make uh the quality
programming and nursing facilities
better so it's findes that are collected
and then reinvested um in two programs
represent tki quick question um my
previous question about hb2 and chairman
Edwards says there any other question on
hb2 and I did do a quick search this
isn't necessarily what this division
looks at but there's a change on the
commission of Commission on Aging which
I assume you are somewhat connected to
um what is your take on the changes in
there it looks like it's adjusting the
membership in some way uh Wendy Alman is
my bureau chief who serves on the
commission of Aging I don't know if you
want to take a mic and you you you you
can sit at the end of the table and use
that last mic and
uh we we just need to make sure the
name good morning um just for the record
uh Wendy Alman I'm the bureau chief of
the Bureau of adult and Aging Services I
am the design from the Department who
sits on the Commission on Aging the
Governor's Commission on Aging and
certainly support um the amendment that
they were putting forward um to add um
an individual to the
commission thank you it it specifies a
change in the length of the
terms yeah we we talked as a commission
uh about those changes um both to adding
an individual and and changing the um
terms and we didn't have any okay
opposition to that
thanks representative now
vano
um yeah I had a quick question on uh
page uh 35 I'm just kind of curious as
to why the Alzheimer's disease and
Related Disorders uh is 100% General
funds given the given the fact that uh
Alzheimer's and the Aging population
across the whole us is uh you know been
pretty PR
uh over the last several years uh any is
this an allocation issue where money for
Alzheimer's is showing up someplace else
from the federal funds or just a
peculiarity of what's funded and what's
not funded sure I I I think part of that
is you know we do get family caregivers
support dollars through other funding
streams federally um this is a portion
where the state pays and and really
provides that uh respit care Grant I
think it's $2,000 you know per person uh
specifically for those caring for
Alzheimer's so it's not like they're
excluded from the family caregivers
support program it's just um you know
we're seeing obviously a rise in in
older adults and the need for um
supporting them in the community so um
we we think it's a pretty vital service
um we just recently did a campaign um on
brain health and awareness um which I
think is on one of the slides as far as
um I think that that was an allocation
in hb2 as well um to make sure that
adults are getting screened in the
importance of you know uh recognizing
early signs of of of Alzheimer's and
Dementia so um it's not that it's not
covered again kind of Peace meal with
other funding sources but um nothing you
know as specific as this where 100% of
these dollars go to families with with
caring for somebody with alzheimer's so
it's just an allocate the fact that it's
100% General funds is just a decision
internally how how we're treating
allocations from federal
money uh I think it's a supplement to
the allocations that we're getting from
federal dollars um I don't I don't know
the history of of this line item as far
as how it you know uh originally got
into our budget but historically um it's
been in there for you know 100% use of
so I don't know if now you want to jump
to developmental
41 and and you you'll you'll also be
moving forward in the governor's um
so we have a county unit
7100 um in the Bureau of Developmental
services for developmental Services um
this is the developmental Services
waiver it's 50% um State funds and then
50% federal funds uh for those who
qualify um for uh developmental services
on the DD waiver so it serves about
5,061 individuals on the waiver um
administered uh in partnership with our
area agency system um and our and our uh
providers uh accounting unit 7016 the
required brain uh disorder Services it
is again a waiver service to wave
institutional care for those who
qualified under a brain uh acquired
brain disorder um the waiver itself is
50% uh federal funds 50% State funds um
it also has an allocation for support of
uh the New Hampshire Brain Injury
Association who is our content um expert
on providing services and linking uh
information referrals to those who are
newly brain injured or those who have a
a long-standing sustained brain injury
and provide really uh great support to
those folks so that is also included in
um
716 7110 is our children's in home
support waiver so this is completely um
self-directed by families uh for
children who are in school um it is
again a 5050 uh funding source for
federal and general funds and it's for
kids with developmental disabilities um
to uh stay at home with their their
parents or family and and receive
services in the
home 7013 is Family Support Services
this is 100% General funds this funds um
are 10 um Family Support councils which
are located within the 10 area agencies
and also provides um operational funding
for our 10 contracted area agencies to
support individuals and families
particularly those who um are not on the
waiver or not eligible for Medicaid
otherwise represent
string uh might be jumping a little bit
but you know we're spending about 75,000
a year on the DD waiver program and the
acquired brain disorder about 95,000
first question I have is uh you know
given the number of people we have in
there what's the range of the amount
we're spending per individual do you
find it's very very narrow that almost
everybody is very close to uh uh to the
mean or is it uh vastly spread out and
or you know are there a few people that
are using a substantial part of the
budget that's the first question I had
yeah I I I think with the the work that
we're doing in it it's it's helping us
determine that before it was kind of uh
we weren't able to track let's say
Trends in you know utilization of a
specific service but I will say that we
see people um on the waiver who are
lower cost using those lower cost
Services because they are more
independent so they might just need
somebody to um help them with
Transportation or help them in their in
their jobs so supported employment but
we also have folks that you know require
some really intensive needs they require
residential services with somebody with
them all the time because of their you
know behavior um because of their um you
know developmental disability and really
need you know somebody one-on-one so we
see a range just based on you know our
person centered uh plans for our
individuals so you you may see a
significant number of of individuals in
the program using say less than $10,000
of services in a year do you think or is
that number even could you make sure
you're hitting the microphone I have but
I will speak into it yeah thank you
thank
you I am trying to find my average I do
have an average cost of you know
somebody on the on the D waiver give me
one second uh your your slide um 4 42
has
73739 is an average right so you know I
was just kind of talking about the
spread yeah so that takes into
consideration those who you know utilize
the lower cost services or less number
of services and those who have you know
High intensive need services so what do
you think the most expensive um person
is in there is five million or is it no
I wouldn't say five million I think
we've seen um some budgets you know for
folks who who require maybe um two staff
members with them at all times um
probably could be as high as 500,000 per
year um and that's why we really
advocated for rates so we can predict um
you know that cost uh right now it's
really um what the provider tells us
they need in order to provide services
to those folks without um you know the
guard rails that a rate system would put
into place so uh you know last term we
put a lot of emphasis on on these rates
but uh just at the at the waiver program
as its entirety not going into The
Individual Services it sounds like
you're doing a tremendous job trying to
um Auto automate and be able to collect
and analyze information second
secondarily I I would hope
understand which of those services are
particularly valuable uh to those in the
waiver programs do you have uh as of
this point say a list of what the top 10
services are in terms of uh what in the
uh DD waiver program that we're spending
money on at this point yes I I don't
have that with me but we we are tracking
that information um I will say to the
first part uh of your um comment when we
um
we're looking at rates on the DD side we
did significant stakeholder engagement
you know not only with area agencies but
with providers with people who receive
the service and listen to them as far as
you know what do you need in order to be
successful um in the community where you
want to live and so that's how we
prioritized specific services that we
targeted rates to um based on that
feedback and also based on a a cost
analysis of providing those Services
versus higher cost residential service
so you're saying with the with the last
waiver increases you didn't spread them
equal percentage across everything you
targeted them based on getting the the
best um need for the uh those
individuals in the program was that I
would say for the last waiver increase
it
was it was probably it was I think it
management so we haven't uh received an
appropri ation for this rate development
that's why we put that um forth as a
prioritized need in order to to do this
plan of prioritizing services that that
the people and providers have told us
that are important um for them um as far
as any rate increases I believe it was
across the board it wasn't um focused on
a specific service so I still hear
concerns and I call it the 25 cent
hamburger everybody gets a hamburger
here's your coupon for 05 cents turn it
into anybody you want and they'll give
you a hamburger and they send it to the
state and the state will pay them 25
cents it's pretty hard to get any
anybody to take that and some of the
services in the program um uh you know
particularly uh in the last you know
before the last bium were extremely
difficult to fill at the at the rates
that were there but um you Pro we
probably wouldn't hear about those that
are easy to fill so uh um you know
without without digging into what those
services are and how they serve serve
those individuals um it's hard to make
specific recommendations in hb2 but if
you have the list of top 10 Services um
and uh how much dollars that represents
um I would be interested in that sure I
think in a later slide um probably at
the end where the prioritized needs were
listed um we listed you know the
services that we wanted to include in
the first phase of you know if rates
were funded um and the fiscal impact of
those rates based on um not only
utilization but um low rates so if
people want a service like Community
participation services but our rate is
so low we don't have any um significant
number of providers to provide that um
Home and Community Based service that's
where we we come into this um you know
quandry of uh I can give you your your
25 you know Cent coupon but if if I
don't have a provider going to give you
a hamburger for 25 cents then you're
stuck with your 25 cent coupon right
with no service or no hamburger uh so to
speak so I think that's you know why we
we feel that rates not only in DD but in
CFI are important in order you know to
attract providers to come I don't as a
provider you don't want to come into a
state not knowing what you're going to
be paid to provide a specific service
when it's something that's not
controlled um and measurable um and um
you know on uh measured as far as what
does it cost to provide that service not
you know I'm telling you it costs
$500,000 to provide me Services um so we
need that sort of methodology and
framework in order for us to you know
look at our Cost Containment but also to
make sure people are getting the actual
services that have been uh funded or
allocated to
them so so I have a question for you
representative Stringham uh I'm
following your conversation and it seems
to me like somebody needs to say Where's
the Beef somewhere in here but but
having said that what you know where is
the beef you it sounds like you have
intuitively put your finger on a key
service that you think is not being made
available because of a rate issue do you
have any specifics in mind that you
might want to mention I don't actually
okay you're you're just doing a sanity
check on it so 75,000 is a lot of money
per year and we want to give a uh get
full benefit for for uh those
individuals and put the put the funds to
best use so all right and um and I think
we did some good things last last term
by
prioritizing rate increases or rate
adjustments to areas that helped okay
well thanks I just wanted to interpret
what I was hearing from you a little
better thank you representative priest
uh thank you Mr chairman uh back on page
uh
41 uh thank you for providing us with
the number of individuals that you are
servicing in the first three accounting
units do you have the number of people
that you have served like in the past
five years to give us the information
whether or not this number is increasing
or decreasing or
or I just would like to have something
to compare this with with the staff that
was in place for those
years yes we we report um case load
numbers out on the fiscal committee
dashboard so we can send that to you as
far as I don't know how far back it
looks yeah at least five years is on
there so you can look at um the number
of case loads and the trending of that
that would be great so so that that's
actually already online then because all
the fiscal committee um statistical
summaries are already there um but if
you could send him a link just to get
him going that would be great thank you
welcome uh representative seaworth thank
you Mr chairman um my question is on the
Family Support Services it's actually a
two-part question um the first part
pardon me I'm going to kind of repeat my
colleagues question before so this is a
100% General funds is this in service to
a federal obligation or is this
something on our own initiative we
decided it's it's necessary yeah it's um
in in Statute in New Hampshire it's not
a federal statute it is um under
126g um for family support um to um to
provide assistance to individuals that
to families that are taking care of
individuals with developmental
disabilities so it's within our um state
statute
um and then um you know providing uh
operating costs for area agencies to
take care of those individuals that
don't have um Medicaid coverage or any
other insurance coverage um the area
agencies are obligated if somebody is um
determined eligible through 171a to
provide you know developmental services
and not necessarily based on if you're
eligible for the waiver so we have a lot
of reports that the area agencies
provide to people who don't qualify for
Medicaid and so so providing funding to
the area agencies to keep um you know
families uh in order to keep families as
you know the primary caregiver but
supplement the cost of doing that but
statute RSA 126g yes and I my my second
question I almost thought it was anti
is going to be answered but so what it
looks like to me is that it's the second
bullet that you mentioned and the other
RSA reference 171a I can certainly go
home and look at that but if there's a
quick elevator summary because it looks
to me in the budget that that's some new
funding um in the upcoming bium so if if
you I I believe you're on page 108 under
7013 so there there's two class lines
there the first class line that has the
Family Support Council dollars budgeted
in state fiscal years 26 and
27 and then in class 103 that is the um
the contracts with the area agencies
that are is budgeted there these these
were both previously budgeted in class
102 but we tried to separate that out to
make it more transparent going forward
and just easier to
track and so
the difference between 24 and 25 in the
102 line is the the difference um so if
if you were to turn to
um give me one second
here so if you were to turn to chapter
106 in the current operating budget it's
budgeted at 4.46 7 million each year
what you see in the state fiscal year 24
actual expense is you're seeing delays
in invoicing and billing so the expenses
did did not occur at that point in time
but the budgeted amounts have remained
flat B or bayum to bayum thank you for
the
explanation so so you got me thinking
about line 103 the $2.9 million that
that those are contracts to area
agencies to provide Area Agency kind of
activities I suppose and I think we
talked about it in January but I asked
the question we've got 10 now if we were
to reduce that to eight would we save
any money the testimony of uh the
department at that point was no you
would just you know move parts and
people around but it would be the same
cost is that still your position yes um
you know we we serve a very um Niche
population so that that population
doesn't changed the number of people we
serve wouldn't change it would just um
you know go to a different agency so we
don't believe it would be a significant
cost savings and and then the big
procedural shift I think we've seen in
the area agencies is previous budgets
area agencies were responsible for doing
basically the billing for the providers
and we've gone to um an independent
direct provider type of billing correct
was there any cost savings to our
contracts to the area agencies since
we're asking them to do
less um I think they're two separate
functions so I would say that um we
haven't we've actually seen uh we're
tracking month over month the actual
spend on the waiver to see you know um
now that the providers are able to
directly Bill instead of having to Bill
through the area agency are we seeing an
increase in Billing or a decrease we've
seen a pretty um I think I have a slide
in here we've seen a pretty consistent
amount of billing whether it's from an
area agency first services or from a
provider for services so we haven't seen
you know a cost shift in
that okay and and then
um it was part of the A&M uh
recommendations where there were three
major things that the department wanted
to do in this current this the current
budget cycle one of them was the
transition the billing and then there
were two other and I forget what the two
others were but you you all ended up
postponing it to to adjust the
absorption rate by the area agencies
what what were the other two items that
uh were on your list of of A&M
recommendations uh a few so we s we had
recommendations for it enhancements
which is certainly something that we
have been working on that is not um it
was briefly paused as we were trying to
figure out operationally how that
happens um with the area agencies and
making sure that um they have sufficient
software technology in order to to
change that uh uh that practice um so we
had it enhancements we had um
investments in um intensive treatment
services uh which we have done through
federal dollars um with our arpa uh
grants that we've um been able to open
um or at least fund at least um 115 new
uh beds in the community for those who
need um a higher level of care um
instead of having to move move out of
state or receive Services um away from
their families um so that was the other
um suggestion that they had okay and so
just to wrap all of that up I I think we
paid A&M I don't know $15 million for
their uh Consulting and they gave us at
least these three big
recommendations can we project any
savings or additional revenues that come
from that contract we invested in are we
are we going to get a return on
investment for that
Consulting I I I think that's a broader
question that I can bring back because
I'm going to have to pull in a couple of
different folks from different areas
there there was a lot more work I mean
currently they're they've been providing
us assistance with the community
re-entry that we previously talked about
when Medicaid was here um when Dave
weers was talking about the
modularization of the uh the mismis
system and moving that towards uh more
of a modular based approach so there
there's quite a few other elements that
they've been helping us with um in the
current bayum there there has been a
significant reduction to that Alvarez
and Marcel contract so going forward it
would only be the DD work and the mmis
and and the other work streams um are
being retired out from that all right
and do you happen to recall offhand what
the hourly Bill rate is for A&M I I I've
heard 180 I've heard 240 an hour um the
the the billing is based on a month
monthly uh amount B and and so we
receive uh a certain chunk of resources
in work hours and then the billing is
done on a on a monthly basis I don't
recall off the top of my head I'd have
to go back and get that okay so I'll
I'll just say one thing that's been
whispered to me in hallways is it would
be much smarter if we went and hired one
or two really smart people that can step
in and take over the A&M implementation
roles so that we're spending money
within oury employment structure rather
than Contracting that out so I'm not I'm
going to I'm not going to ask you your
opinion on that here but I just want to
share the feedback that I've been
getting about the A&M contract so if
there if there if there if there's
something to that idea that you want to
act on you know come back and let us
know
okay um do you want to continue yeah I I
think one other point I just want to
make um Within slide 41 is that um our
our rates were uh based on um we we used
another contractor not A&M to look at
you know the cost structure of those
rates uh uh uh one of the components was
using an assessment um to uh to assess
the level of need that an individual uh
may need as far as uh a support uh the
supports intensity scale um and that is
not only um in our rules but in our
waiver um that has been unfunded um so
that would be I'm just trying to put a
plug out there as far as um
considerations for you know our our rate
base methodology is you know a component
of that is having that um individual uh
assessment of of of Need for people um
on the waiver who are adults so um I
was there a question over on this side
no um slide 42 is um again just um
examples of um our three waivers in um
developmental services and the average
cost the historical average cost per
year services rendered um and
eligibility requirements
slide 43 is a billing slide um which is
25 um data and and I just wanted to
point out you can see that um in that
first box in the upper left hand side um
92% of the billing is for the DD waiver
um so you can see we have that's where
our most of our billing goes is for
those Services um the the major service
types of billing that we're seeing is
67% for residential services and 23% for
day service says um so we have a a a
monthly billing average of about $ 43.4
million um for um the DD for all of the
waivers in BDS so we're seeing and we're
seeing that pretty consistently since
we've been tracking um July we've been
tracking longer but since July 24 you
can see that's pretty consistent bill so
because I'm I'm trying to manage the
time yep um would would would would you
uh would we be missing something
significant if we went to slide
50 that's where the uh prioritized needs
that I I don't I don't want to jump
something that you had put an aster by
it so starting on slide 50 is um a list
of the prioritized needs that our
division put forth um you can see that
uh for the BDS waivers we were funded
for um our weight list requests so these
are um tracked um for individuals who
are projected to need services that are
currently not funded U because they're
not in the system so our area agencies
help us um in a registry system to
project um new people coming on the
waiver and people who might need
enhancements to the services that
they're providing so um that was funded
um that's that's what you hear uh when
you hear the wait list that's that's
what was funded uh as part of our
prioritized need so so for the newer
people to the division and and just to
make sure I I understand it um we often
speak in terms of saying we are funding
the weight list and what that means is
that the money is in the budget to
theoretically pay for everyone that
needs the BDS service however the
reality is that there is often a
disconnect between um uh our ability to
fund the service and the individual
actually receiving the service and so
the real weight list is the number of
people who aren't being serviced even
though there's money and so don't don't
get complacent when you hear that we
fully funded to make sure that we have
no weit list because that's not the
question the question is how many people
need the service that aren't able to
access the service I think that's the
effec of wait list and that's a harder
statistic to to maintain right but I
think you all have broken the code and
now you report as routinely what the
actual number of people who who want
services but can't correct okay yep and
and and the reasons why so is it because
they can't find a provider to secure the
service is it um you know they they need
Medicaid you know eligibility so there's
a there's a lot of factors that we uh
now report out at at oversight as to yes
funding is is you know people are funded
but why are they not accessing the
service and that's reported um to us
from our area agency system so um that's
you know something part of Again part of
our it technology that we were able to
build but also um really taking that
stock and being transparent of yeah we
we don't have a funding weight list but
people aren't getting all the services
that are authorized so so this 44
million in 27 is feels just like an
enormous jump so you have to remember in
in 27 not only you would you be funding
the new people on 27 but you also have
to an uh annualize the folks that you're
funding in 26 so you'll see you know
because if you fund people in 26 they
also need funding in
27 what's are I this isn't the right
word but I'm I'm going to say attrition
rate we're we're we're looking we're
looking for new people who need the
services while at the same time at the
back end of the system people are are no
longer requiring services for a variety
of reasons so so are do are you also
projecting in this the um attrition rate
yes but I would say it's fairly low
because these are Services throughout
somebody 's lifespan right so it's not
if you compare it to somebody on CFI
who's an older adult um you know I would
say the attrition is higher because you
have a a shorter life lower range right
right um where these people's range is
much longer exactly so you have kids you
have kids coming in from school all the
way through adulthood on you know being
eligible for DD service you made that
make sense for me thank you
welcome what what else uh so we also uh
we put in our prioritized need for CFI
rate increase based on hb2 system of
care um as we were um legislated to do a
rate study so we put that in our
prioritized need we also um in listening
to our stakeholders put in a prioritized
need for guardianship slots um for uh
people who are on the DD waiver and
people and and older
adults um congregate housing which was
something
um that was
unfunded was unfunded we put in as a
prioritized need um that was not funded
um then we have the the BDS rat which
we've talked about one um really
important consideration on page 51 is
the uh prioritized need for room and
board um we have providers um on the DD
and ABD waiver that provide residential
services for for people and room and
board costs are not covered by the
waiver or by Medicaid and so we have
providers with Rising costs of utilities
of um you know so of this 10 million how
much of that is General funds all 10
million and you know I I think there's a
a slide on kind of I don't want to say a
justification but you know the
importance of we we've done work over
the past two years and developing a
formula for uh room and board rates as
to looking at you know what county you
live in the number of beds that you're
um certified as a provider in your home
looking at um rental costs per County
looking at utility costs phone and
internet uh property costs which could
include you know snow removal air
conditioning that sort of thing and food
costs um the the real danger and not
funding this prioritized need is that
we've heard from providers that they
just cannot keep the service going
without those additional costs
supplemented um and so again none of our
Medicaid waiver dollars can pay for room
and board that pay for services for the
individual um the individuals do pay um
toward that room and board cost um but
it's not enough to cover the cost to
keep um doors open for our providers so
you know potential concerns would be not
only providers leaving the state not um
not attracting new providers to the
state but also UNH housing people with
developmental disabilities and where
would they go if they did not have that
Residential
Care represent wner how many people
affect how many people that's kind of a
hard one to guess I would think because
you don't know who's going to drop out
and who's going to be affected but yeah
yeah um I I can I can look at more of
the numbers on that I can get you kind
of the number of certified beds and who
you know currently has room and board
funding but I would say um even the
current roomin board funding that these
providers are receiving um is not enough
with you know without an adjustment
factor to you know the changing costs
and
service I would I would appreciate
seeing what you know some sort of we can
do that estimate of so how many people
are getting room in board now
um that's a good question and then do
you have a unmet need of the number of
people who still need room in board that
don't have it now what what are those
two numbers yeah we certainly still have
providers that are providing services
without room and board um and and those
um as we were you know creating a
formula to make it fair and uh it used
to be kind of first come first serve so
if I was a provider and I asked for room
and board we have a finite amount of
dollars currently um that we can use for
room and board sure I'm just asking
client numbers how many clients
currently benefit from room and board
and what is our unmet we got somebody
okay because because I think that gives
representative walner and the rest of us
an idea of what the potential impact is
here thank you she's looking it up so
soon as soon as we get that we can okay
she can continue need to look it up um
Let me let me do a survey question and
as we're pausing are there members of
the audience that would like to speak to
the committee this morning before we we
break I'm not I'm not seeing hands I'm
not seeing hands
okay um do you want to talk about
Recreation and and intervent early
intervention while she's coming up with
the numbers yeah we can talk briefly
about Recreation as we know that was
funded in 202 see fiscal year 2025 with
$500,000 of um General funds yeah how'd
that go do we have any data on on
utilization we do so I looked last night
before as I Was preparing for this
morning so as of uh last night we've
$367,500 approvals and only one denial
because um that person was not receiving
waiver services so not U part of the
criteria to um receive these Recreation
funds so were your big numbers 360,000
divided by about 227 users um I would
say divided by 673 users six so and
there's a cap of $600 so they can't ask
for more than $600 for Recreation
services okay um do we have the numbers
can you just that's our that's our if if
can we're about to hear I
think good morning I'm Jessica Gorton
the bureau chief with the Bureau of
Developmental services and my colleague
Lorie Bashon is pulling the numbers of
individuals who are currently receiving
ran board funding we have about a list
of 500 individuals right now who need
Ren board funding that's been provided
by our provider agencies 500 in addition
to whatever number we already are
supporting in addition to the current
spend which we typically Track by
provider but they should be very quickly
able to um divide that by the total
number of individuals so the immediate
threat is probably could be summarized
that those 500 may not be serviced and
that of the existing client population
they may be harmed because some unknown
percentage will have it their room and
board re removed absolutely due to the
total impact to a provider agency as a
whole and not any one particular home
that they might be receiving those funds
mron do you want to come up did you have
a
number hi thank you I'm Lori vashan the
Chief Operating Officer for the division
of long-term supports and services at
this time we have a total of about
240 um beds that providers could bill
for there are sometimes a vacancy if an
individual passes away and then somebody
else moves into the home but overall we
have on average about
550 approved um staffed
residential individuals in New Hampshire
so um that's the unmet
need I I'm getting my numbers confused
the current people receiving Services
sounds to be a little under 250 no So
currently receiving so we only only have
a a smaller population that we're able
to fund room and board services for and
that's around 240 individuals or beds in
New Hampshire so we're only doing a
third of the demand correct correct okay
and
um just to reemphasize what Melissa
Hardy said it's critical to keep those
individuals receiving current Services
yep no I I understand I I I think we
just wanted to understand the context
the human impact in in quantitative
numbers so thank you thank
you okay do you do you do you have a do
you have a question I'm sorry were there
questions over here there were questions
over there but I do have representative
priest thank you Mr chairman back on
page just quickly on page 50 on guardian
and on congregate housing do you also
have numbers of people that we serve and
what's the need for that I do um and you
can provide this afterwards if if it's
not easy to get to yes I do have numbers
for that that I can get to you as far as
the number of current slots that we have
for Guardianship and then um I know
there's also
legislation um currently going on as far
as as uh funding um this guardianship
need and and what that would mean is you
know the increasing the number of slots
but also increasing the rate that uh
public Guardians received to provide
that service great and the same with
congregate housing yes um congregate
housing um was something that was funded
um in hb2 and um was um not funded
during the governor's budget uh we have
two providers um that are um housing
authorities in Laconia and in Manchester
that um receive this support uh through
congregate housing so that could be um
support service
you know housekeeping services for those
individuals that live in those um
housing
developments okay thank
you go ahead so that was the question I
had had about the suspension in hb2 I
guess my followup to that is all these
other line items that are not funded on
your prioritized list
is that congregate housing the only
thing that's in statute how come that's
the only thing that is suspended
officially that's a question for you Mr
White sure so congregate housing um it
was funded at 1.5 million by NH hb2
appropriation in the current bium y
prior to that um I I would have to go
back and look at the history I don't
know if Kevin knows off the top of his
head it's been unfunded for a number of
Bania it was it was one of the it was
one of the items last go around when uh
chairman Edwards asked the question of
why do we keep suspending this we've
never funded it but then last year we
funded it so um different conversation
now uh but it just has a history of not
being funded for some time okay so my
followup question though is these other
line items that were not funded how come
we don't have to suspend anything for
those because they're not in statute or
so the congregate housing that's the
entire program so so under statute it
directs us to um have a program for that
but if we do not then uh then we would
recommend suspending that the the CFI
service rate incre the rate increased
the guardianship rate increase the BDS
service rate increase you're not closing
down a program for a b so you wouldn't
necessarily need to suspend the state
law so there's that was my question so
there none of these other ones are at
no okay um that is that the do you have
like a just a short summary because then
I'm going to ask you about some
questions that may affect uh some
thinking around long-term managed
care one other item just um to be aware
of that we previously discussed just
when we're talking about prioritized
needs um in in the governor's budget in
the H sorry in the
hb2 um there is a provision to continue
the DD pilot program um that was
originally authorized in chapter or
chapter 79 for the current bium um and
that extends the program to allow us to
continue to use the funds that were
previously appropriated until the seven
or eight individuals age off that pilot
program uh so I just wanted to highlight
that as well just as we're talking about
uh
DD okay so so so make it simple for me
is is that would that need to be another
line on this prioritized need list like
an extension of page 51 it it would not
no action is currently necessary it's
section 104 of hb2 that makes that
extension I just wanted to highlight
that in case there were any
consideration for changing that
okay not that I'm recommending it all
right um all right so we have a a few
minutes and uh and so there's been some
discussion and this will be made more
formal representative tersi rep
representative walner um but but I I
just want to start getting some thought
out into the onto the table and in the
public there's been some discussion
around um maybe uh asking for this next
budget to begin a transition period for
um uh the long-term supports the the CFI
and the like moving it um into the
Managed Care Organization structure and
if we did that um the Managed Care
organizations would would then need to
take care of uh issues like um uh
discharge planning Transitional Care
other educational programs to Physicians
and hospitals uh we would have have to
uh have the Managed Care Organization
start to provide those
Services um and they would need to uh
assist in collecting financial
information uh provide payment
incentives to nursing facilities to
reward reductions in several types of
problems and uh to develop a shared
Savings Program for the county
governments so so those are the big
things the mcos would need to do among
you know some other obvious impl
implementation stuff but but then some
the counties would need to be um more in
included more than they are now in doing
the um medical evaluations to help
assess the level of need um and uh and
so there would need to be a transition
period where the counties uh were able
to establish Manpower and training and
put themselves in a position um I I I
know that this topic has come up ever
since we started doing mcos and I know
that every time it's come up uh a
decision has been made to leave it
outside of the Managed Care
structure um but but but based on the
rambling I just did and you not having
any paper in front of you do you have do
you have any uh basic comments on this I
see Mr Lipman has come in uh and um do
you do you you want to respond to that
in any way I would want to recommend
that you know this was a discussion I
think about 12 years ago um you know
having ltss and managed care I think it
it got pretty far um but did not um
produce ltss in managed care I think
there's a lot of considerations in
looking at that um moving people into a
medical model versus a person centered
model you know how would we um that's
That's the basis of all of our services
right not necessarily from a medical
perspective or an insurance perspective
what's makes sense so I think you know
how do we balance the preservation of
our our system as Home and Community
Based as person centered uh versus being
managed by you know a larger insurer um
I I think that would be something that
we would need um technical assistance or
Consulting on you know from States or
partners that have done it before that
have moved into Managed Care U I think
it's a bit beyond and above what what
our capacity is to to look at all the
risks and benefits of doing that not
just you know looking at the cost
savings but looking at the impact on you
know the services that people uh receive
as of right now it's very you know
person driven so I I would want to
caution in you making sure that we have
a you know a thoughtful plan that
includes you know stakeholder provider
uh input as to how would it affect you
know an individual receiving services
but also providers um you know being
reimbursed for those Services provided
yeah so so I I always try to play a
little bit of a devil's advocate with my
questions and so when I'm hearing this
my devil's advocacy question is why
would we do this we we we have a system
it's working you know what what what do
we think the benefits of a change like
this might might be and what has been
offered back is that we initially had
some estimates on the number of people
that we thought would take advantage of
CFI we we've not been hitting those
numbers and and and and so as we've
talked and agreed upon before there's
not only a cost savings but a quality of
life benefit for people who don't need
to go into nursing homes and can stay at
home longer so between the financial and
personal if we found a way to uh drive
up uh the the number of people in
cfis and reduce the number of people in
County homes that that could provide for
significant um uh quality of life
improvements while saving considerable
money and the and the and the belief is
that the mcos they had the
accountability for those long-term
dollars then they would have more of an
incentive to aggressively manage that
program so so that's the answer to my
why would we do this question and and I
just leave that out for you not for
comment but for context thank you um so
um it's it's pretty much noon are there
any you're you're thinking do you have
questions or comments on this topic I'm
sure I will I know I wasn't expecting
the conversation right representative
well and and I I wanted to make it part
of the conversation to tee up a real
walner okay well I I don't know how how
we did it but it's noon and uh I'm going
to um adjourn this this uh this work
much
e